überraschende wende im ukraine krieg die
ukraine haben in wenigen tagen mehr
gelände zurück erobert als ihnen die
russische armee in den letzten monaten
geklaut hat wahnsinn ja putins verbände
sind wohl heißt es in panik geflohen
oder in den worten der kreml propaganda
sie haben sich umgruppiert ja so heißt
das jetzt offiziell umgruppierung man
sagt in russland auch nicht mehr fliehen
das heißt jetzt rückwärts anlauf nehmen
und der chef der tut dabei so als wäre
gar nichts passiert putin selbst gibt
sich betont gelassen eröffnet am
wochenende das größte riesenrad europas
doch auch hier zeigt sich wie weit
gerade anspruch und wirklichkeit
auseinanderklaffen schon nach einem tag
funktioniert es nicht mehr
putin hatten laufen am selben tag hat er
tatsächlich noch in moskau ein neues
kampfsport zentrum eröffnet ja alles um
sein volk von der militärischen blamage
in der ukraine abzulenken ist der plan
aber der funktioniert nicht mehr
funktioniert nicht mehr trotz propaganda
dauerfeuer und wirklich permanente
einschüchterung hört man in russland
jetzt sogar offene kritik an putin
wirklich dabei kennt die russische
sprache das wort kritik gar nicht hier
wirklich extrem mutige kommunalpolitiker
die welt hat wieder angefangen sich vor
russland zu fürchten und es zu hassen
und russland bedroht die welt wieder mit
nuklearwaffen und dann bitten sie putin
er möge doch zurücktreten
oder echt krass a move in einem land wo
man schon für weit weniger nach sibirien
umgruppiert wird
und hier in deutschland ist jetzt
natürlich der panzer streit wieder voll
entbrannt das war ja klar olaf scholz
oder wie seine fans ihn nennen der
zauberer von oz
olaf scholz bleibt dabei deutschland
liefert keine kampfpanzer an die ukraine
punkt weil das ja ein alleingang weber
und unsere partner vor allem die
amerikaner dann stinksauer vehren sagte
was hat dich das argument nur die
amerikaner haben diesen hinweis ja als
ausrede en tant die us-botschaft hier in
berlin war ja so nett mitzuteilen dass
natürlich jeder gerne so viel liefern
könne wie er wolle
verdammte amis machen unsere ganzen
geilen ausreden kaputt thanks for
nothing
ich sag mal wer will dass der terror
gegen zivilisten in der ukraine aufhört
muss denen liefern was dazu nötig ist
und wenn man das nicht tut ist es absurd
gleichzeitig zu behaupten ausgerechnet
deutschland seine militärische
führungsmacht sowie unsere
verteidigungsministerin diese woche was
nimmt die denn
führungsmacht die führungsmacht
deutschland führt große reden aber das
führt zu nichts
kevin köhler zum beispiel sagt aktuell
bloß keine panzer liefern sonst könnte
putin zitat irrational reagieren
verstehen sie also nicht mehr so
rationale und vernünftig wie bisher und
was mich interessieren würde was sagen
jetzt eigentlich hier unsere
intellektuellen diese ganzen deutschen
klugscheißer die seit monaten behaupten
die ukraine hätte keine chance richard
david precht zb der müsste dringend mal
wieder einen offenen brief schreiben
liebe ukraine was soll das denn jetzt
ich hab doch schon im frühjahr ganz
deutlich gesagt ihr hättet zitat die
pflicht zur klugheit einzusehen wenn man
sich ergeben muss und jetzt fangt ihr
plötzlich an zu gewinnen
habt ihr euch mal eine sekunde lang
gefragt wie ich jetzt da stehe ich kann
nicht auch hollands gar nicht mehr
blicken lassen wo soll ich abends hin
würde mir gern vor wut die haare raufen
aber dann liegen sie nicht mehr
menschlich enttäuscht euer richie
er ist so süß wenn er traurig ist können
wir jetzt bitte wieder über uns reden
geht hast was ist denn jetzt mit
deutschland wir sind wieder weltmeister
ja wir sind wie der weltmeister fuhr
aber in was denn eigentlich unsere
energie ist die teuerste der welt auch
so
scheiße
ja tatsächlich zahlen deutsche
unternehmen ungefähr zehn mal so viel
für energie die ihre amerikanischen und
chinesischen konkurrenten blüht so
ärgerlich dass die ampel bei all den
vielen entlastungs paketen ausgerechnet
kleine mittelständische betriebe
vergessen hat er kreist uns ein schon
mal passiert
mal vergisst du den autoschlüssel mal
den mittelstand es bräuchte jetzt und
zwar ganz schnell einen preis deckel für
den grundtarif bei strom und gas ja ganz
schnell stattdessen diskutieren wir aber
von morgens bis abends über drei
popelige atomkraftwerke und entscheiden
uns nach all dem bestreite am ende
wieder für den arsch teuren deppen
kompromiss sie werden einsatzbereit
gehalten kühlkreisläufe werden nicht
unterbrochen sicherheitschecks werden
weiter durchgeführt das personal wird
auch gehalten aber sie produzieren
keinen strom
toll ist so toll
optimal wäre haben wir die kosten
produzieren aber keine einzige
kilowattstunde supi im übrigen würden
diese akw es im streck betrieb den
strompreis so gut wie gar nicht und den
gaspreis überhaupt gar nicht senken
lassen
theaterleute man im worst case im
absoluten worst case käme es vielleicht
zu vereinzelten blackouts in bayern also
nicht mal in deutschland
und schön die bayern wollten das doch so
hoch wie blockieren seit jahren
windräder und stromtrassen bei sich und
werden so verdient zum neuen dunkel
deutschland
willkommen zur neuen kult gaudi 20 22
künftigen blackout wiesen man kann
nämlich auch ohne strom spaß haben ab
sofort gibt's kein tennis mehr nur noch
dunkles ist das eine weißwurst oder
leberkäs egal alles die gleiche pappe
hat der kellner gekleckert oder hat mir
ein japaner in den lappen gekotzt wen
juckts und sind wir mal ehrlich das
meiste was auf der wiesn passiert will
man nicht den regeln sehen dies wird der
rabenschwarze gabi gut dass wir die
stromtrassen gebaut haben die black out
wiesen 22
wie gesagt mein persönliches mittel hat
hält sich in grenzen wenn er wir müssen
sowieso alle energie sparen wissen sehr
zum beispiel weniger duschen es ist ja
so es ist ja so
puls bleiben unbeheizt deutsche beamte
zittern in 19 grad kalt büros weiß nicht
anders geht und viele deutsche kommunen
gehen sogar noch weiter so sieht es hier
normalerweise aus doch jetzt links nur
noch verhalten die straßenlaternen
werden gedämmt die schwimmbecken
runtergekühlt auf kalte duschen müssen
sich auch schulen und vereine in
kaiserslautern einstellen und sogar
ampeln sollen abgeschaltet werden die
stadt augsburg erweckt das krematorium
künftig bei niedrigeren temperaturen zu
betreiben
und geht doch auch wird wird oberhalb
suite gegart
apropos oper apropos oper winfried
kretschmann
hat diese woche er hat diese woche im
fernduell mit putin den nächsten
energiesparclub rausgehauen es ist
wirklich der nackte wahnsinn was man von
kretschmann alles lernen kann herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge von
winfried reß vladimir smackdown für
freunde ab jetzt kennt putin sein waren
endgegner wenige waschlappen kretschmann
hat schon wieder zugeschlagen mit einer
gnadenlosen propagandaoffensive im
energie krieg alle ansteigen das hier
haben sie garantiert noch nie gehört
nachts wenn alle schlafen wird wir halt
zu runtergefahren das kann jede und
jeder an seiner heizung selbst
einstellen und wem das zu kompliziert
ist einfach vorn ins bett gehen den
terror stark behindert
genial oder ich habe mich immer gefragt
wozu diese zahlen auf diesem weißen
drehten sie sind und jetzt stellt sich
raus damit kann ich die heizung
runterdrehen und zwar auf 1 ein
forscherteam aus wie die staatskanzlei
hat herausgefunden 1 ist wohl eine der
niedrigsten zahlen überhaupt noch vor 0
der pullover wärmt irisch aber vorsicht
das teil hat vier löcher dafür tut man
sich schnell ein großes das ist das
eingangs loch
[Musik]
scheiße kretschmann konnte das schon
immer besser erklären als ich
kretschmann kann alles besser erklären
da jetzt einen vorschlag gemacht
dass man zwei bei der klospülung spart
indem man zum beispiel eine zwei stufen
regelung macht entsprechend den
physiologischen bedürfnissen dorfen kilo
client groß oder so machen wir es
zuhause gar nicht mehr spielen
überall lauern die energiefresser was
viele nicht wissen die meisten
kühlschränke haben eine so genannte tür
die man zu machen kann
das hält die kälte drinnen und jetzt
kommt der clou das lichter drin geht
angeblich aus doppelt gespart fragen sie
sich jeden tag was würde winfried machen
was in meiner wohnung verbraucht unnötig
viel energie was kann ich einsparen
oder wen kann ich einsparen jede
kilowattstunde
sag ich mir ein feuer machen nein
brennholz ist teuer
winfried was ist vladimir schmeckt
ja
wir schmunzeln er aber kretschmann hat
nicht unrecht wir müssen energie sparen
übrigens segler wegen putin auch wegen
klima müssen sie noch klima er ist ja
fast schon bewundernswert wie wir uns
als gesellschaft schaffen das thema
klimaschutz schon wieder komplett zu
verdrängen nachdem der sommer ist schon
irre wie wir das hinkriegen
meldung aus dieser woche es gibt einen
neuen rekord bei der pkw dichte pro 1000
einwohner in deutschland
580 autos ja ein trend setzt sich fort
denn tatsächlich hat unser
verkehrssektor seit 1990 ja so gut wie
kein co2 eingespart aber hey das wird
jetzt natürlich mit der ampel garantiert
alles besser heute nachmittag im
bundestag wollte der
bundesverkehrsminister seine
investitionspläne für die zukunft
vorstellen der herr bundesminister der
als erster regnen sollte hat mitteilen
lassen dass er sich im verkehr befindet
das passt ja auch gut
ja keine
besser und verkehrsminister sitz im
verkehr als ein bauminister aber
ja volker wissing hat da gerade leicht
verspätet seine pläne vorgestellt und
zumindest beim thema klima ist da
wirklich noch sehr viel luft nach oben
sehr viel luft meine immerhin
immerhin steht im ampel
koalitionsvertrag man wolle zitat
erheblich mehr in die schiene als in die
straße investiert cool wie viel mehr ist
es denn geworden für neue straßen 3,8
milliarden euro für neue schienen nur
2,1 milliarden
siehst du genau so wie es geplant war
halt anders herum
volker wissing kämpft weiter eisern fürs
deutsche brumm brumm unser aus puff
daddy
zugegebenermaßen jetzt kein
klimaschützer im engeren sinne anna
dafür ein astreiner komiker wir wollen
eine
hochleistungsfähige deutsche bahn die
sicher und pünktlich die bürgerinnen und
bürger an ihre ziele bringt wir wollen
dass man wieder die uhr nach der bahn
stellen können ja und ich will
schulterlanges volles haar meine damen
und herren
wird beides nicht passieren der
verkehrssektor hat im letzten jahr 3,1
megatonnen co2 mehr verballert als
eigentlich erlaubt auch deshalb musste
herr bisschen in den sommerferien
nachsitzen während die glücklichen
kollegen am strand waren und ein
sofortprogramm mit neuen maßnahmen
vorlegen anschließend streng geprüft von
einem sogenannten experten rat der
sachverständigen und expertenrat hat
sich geweigert es im detail zu prüfen in
der schule wäre dass die schulnote 6
thema verfehlt setzen
eine glatte sechs mit solchen noten wird
man normalerweise nicht verkehrsminister
sondern schiebt bei lidl die
einkaufswagen zusammen
er kann sich ja noch steigert die
deutsche umwelthilfe hat wissen gerade
verklagt und zwar völlig zu recht ein
drittel der von ihm geplanten
einsparungen basiert auf der hoffnung
dass auch im nächsten jahr quasi alle im
home office arbeiten ja er setzt auf
spritsparende lkw-anhänger also
wahrscheinlich auf leere anhänger
und er kalkuliert wirklich war mit mehr
seilbahn in deutschen städten ist
ausdrücklich kein witz ja
wirklich ja es ist so schade dass der
expertenrat wissings sofortprogramm
nicht zu ende lesen wollte da standen
noch so tolle ideen drin zb die
pendlerpauschale nicht nur für papa
sondern auch für den junior der neue
bobbycar bonus rutschautos sind
weitgehend co2 neutral wissen viele gar
nicht außerdem will wissing
kreuzfahrtschiffe auf handbetrieb und
stellen und auch realistisch er will
deutlich mehr lkws auf unseren straßen
also einhorn gezogene kraftfahrzeuge was
ist denn bloß mit volker wissing los ist
das spannende frage kann er nicht oder
will er nicht wir schalten wir live ins
verkehrsministerium zu seiner
staatssekretärin valerie niehaus von
hier aus dieser sechs punkte plan den
ihr chef dahin gehandelt hat der ist ja
wohl arbeitsverweigerung ja also gut
herr werke da sind sie jetzt aber auch
ein stückweit opfer ihres eigenen meint
setzen also das alte wir strampeln uns
für unsere firma kaputt denken das mag
sie jetzt schockieren aber der völker
und wir wir definieren uns halt mich so
über den job
also hier der hendrick zum beispiel der
leitet gerade den arbeitskreis
fahrradwege aus
also er stellt sich vor dass demnächst
jemand mehr fahrradwege baut also es ist
wirklich nicht böse gemeint aber ich
habe das gefühl sie kriegen die neuesten
trends in der arbeitswelt gar nicht mehr
so mit kammern seien stille kündigungen
im englischen quaid kritik unter diesem
begriff bringen gerade ganz viele junge
menschen zum ausdruck dass sie
überstunden nicht länger hinnehmen
wollen nicht mehr ausschließlich für den
job leben wollen dienst nach vorschrift
ist der neue heiße scheiß die coolen
leute könnten also was wollen sie von
mir ja
mir tut das ja auch leid wenn der
klimawandel dem volker die
work-life-balance versaut aber jedes
ministerium ist doch für seine co2
bilanz verantwortlich auch der verkehr
ja das sagen sie ich kenne einen
wunderschönen mann der sagt was anderes
die ampel hat in ihrem koalitionsvertrag
verabredet dass wir anders als die
vorgängerregierung nicht mehr nur den
einzelnen sektor also zb verkehr ansehen
sondern dass wir stärker
sektorübergreifend die klimaziele
miteinander verrechnen wollen so
geht teamarbeit nicht also wenn wir beim
verkehr mal nicht genug einsparen oder
immer dann gleichen das halt andere
sektoren aus seien sie doch froh die fdp
ist endlich weg vom leistungsprinzip
also jetzt nicht bei hartz iv
aber also schnell bei uns selbst ja
meine der bausektor muss auch nachsitzen
aber die bemühen sich wenigstens echte
vorschläge zum bausektor blöde schreiber
schwein
wir haben auch viel geleistet tempolimit
verhindert verbrenner aus verhindert was
dennoch der erfolg hatte heute sogar
einen regelrechten termin der muss so
neues hightech equipment für die bahn
ein bein
die pfeife heftig also von wegen bei der
bahn funktioniert nichts so ihr pfeifen
wir gehen jetzt nach hause getreu
unserem neuen ministeriums motto
lieferbar sing mit volker wissing
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die leute ich wollte euch nur um ein
kleines auto bieten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
hallo
hast du scheiße fährt haye